hi everyone can you uh can you see
me we should be live yeah okay
awesome thank you everyone for joining
the gradio 4.0 launch event uh we're
very very happy to see everyone here um
and we will go ahead and get started so
my name is Abu Bakr Abid I lead the
gradio team at hugging face and today
what we're going to talk about is
basically what we've been up to for the
last few months so the gradio team so
myself and you'll hear from a few of my
colleagues as well um we've been looking
at how uh really the community has been
using gradio and just building some very
very incredible applications and we've
kind of taken that and kind of Tred to
understand how people using gradio and
use that to build in kind of bake in uh
some really uh hopefully I think you'll
find very interesting very nice features
into gradio and we're very excited to
share that with you today so I'll be
talking as well as a few of my
colleagues uh so if you've used gradio
before um I think this will be
interesting maybe you'll get to see some
of the faces behind gradio uh just out
of curiosity and maybe you can kind of
share in the chat uh are people here
generally would you say are you new to
gradio or have you kind of you know are
you pretty proficient with gradio or
somewhere in the
middle if you're joining from YouTube or
LinkedIn we're kind of mirroring to both
LinkedIn and YouTube you can drop you
can kind of comment in the uh in the
comments and then we'll be able to see
that as
organizers
cool
um okay so we have Duke saying uses a
daily some folks who are proficient some
folks it looks like there's a there's a
there's quite a bit of a mix so awesome
okay let's get started so I want to
start by actually setting the stage a
little bit here um I truly believe that
we're at a historic moment in the usage
of machine learning uh so my background
is in Academia so I did my PhD in
machine learning you know quite a while
ago and I remember even just you know up
until a few years ago building machine
learning models was kind of Niche and
when you trained machine learning models
you typically built them for other
machine learning engineers and scientist
to use um there really wasn't this idea
that you know I'm going to publish a I'm
going to train a model and I'm going to
publish it so that anyone can use it out
there then about maybe five or six years
ago uh hugging face came out with the
Transformers library and that's when it
became like possible for software
Engineers who didn't who didn't
necessarily know machine learning to
start using machine learning models in
the last couple of years something crazy
has happened uh which is that pretty
much anyone who knows how to use a
browser can access and use
state-of-the-art machine learning models
and that's been made possible through
demos um through guies that basically
wrap machine learning models and allow
people to use them in interesting ways
and in many ways I think this parallels
the development of uh you know personal
Computing devices personal computers
initially it was just hackers maybe very
sophisticated Engineers who knew how to
use them and now you know personal
computers we're all using them we're all
joining through our phones or or our
laptops and so kind of the same thing
has happened with machine learning demos
you know machine learning demos now go
viral anyone can use them and that's led
to a lot of very interesting
developments there are some downsides so
for example now you there's a lot of
increased scrutiny uh we've seen
regulation around machine learning
models but it's also led to a lot of
very very cool uh development so why are
these uh demos so important why are
machine learning demos why are machine
learning guies so important well first
of all as I've mentioned they increase
the accessibility of machine learning uh
it makes it possible for anyone you know
regardless of their background
regardless of their level of experience
uh uh in in machine learning it lets
them try out machine learning demos um
it exposes hidden biases in machine
learning models so what do I mean by
that so oftentimes you have
state-of-the-art machine learning models
they do they seem to do really well um
you can kind of you know throw uh you
know you'll see really nice blog posts
you'll see kind of very cool examples
where the machine learning model is
doing really well but then you start
giving it maybe a little bit unusual
examples uh maybe examples from
different parts of the world where maybe
it might not have been trained so here's
actually a state-of-the-art machine
learning model uh that was trained with
images of uh it was trained to recognize
images really it's an image classifier
and it was when it's given a picture of
a bride on the on the uh from the West
on the left um it classifies it as bride
or dress or woman which are all
reasonable predictions when given a
picture of a bride from Pakistan where
I'm from it actually classifies it as
performance or costume which is
incorrect and you know maybe even
borderline offensive so by making these
models accessible and available to
everyone we help you know actually
improve that the underlying models
themselves or identify the kind of the
the the the the biases or the weaknesses
in the model and then lastly I think
demos are really powerful because they
refocus researchers onto what's actually
useful to users rather than on
benchmarks
so we we you know many of us might have
seen kind of quantitative benchmarks
okay how good is you know this accuracy
or this other metric uh but a lot of
times what's actually useful to real
users is not some something that's a
little bit harder to capture
quantitatively um and I'll just give one
example from a model that's Tren from a
uh from a demo that's trending right now
in hugging face this is a this is a a
demo for a model called latent uh
consistency model and what it does is is
generate images that are very
stylistically and kind of character-wise
very consistent from one to another now
this isn't traditionally something
that's you know you can easily capture
in a metric but it's something that's
very important to users you know users
who might want to use AI generated
images in you know comic books or or
kind of any sort of visual Graphics they
want to be able to generate consistent
graphics and so by by allowing users to
try out your model through these goys
you can kind of you know you can kind of
understand what users are actually
interested in and it helps align machine
learning research with what users
actually
want cool so I hope that makes sense um
this is kind of why at gradio we're very
excited by Machine learning models U at
hugging face we're very super interested
in in in demos or what we call spaces
it's one of like the three pillars of
machine learning you know data sets
models and spaces or demos but then this
begs the question how do you actually
build demos um and if you're new to
gradio or if you haven't used it before
uh I talked to a lot of people uh who
are who want to actually build demos for
their machine learning model they've
trained something you know pretty cool
they want to build a demo around it they
want to show it off with a web app or a
mobile app um but then they quickly
realize they have to learn flask you
know Docker uh just to kind of wrap
their uh machine learning model in a way
that can serve predictions then they
need to learn JavaScript CSS you know
front end Technologies and then it's
just like you know uh maybe it's okay I
actually don't need to show off my
machine learning model with a web app um
and so this is why we built gradio
really um we built gradio because we
wanted it to be possible for anyone to
very very easily in just a few lines of
python create a guei for their machine
learning uh model and then serve it in a
way that can you know scale up to
thousands of users if uh you know if you
want um and so if You' if you haven't
used gradio before it's extremely uh
simple uh to get started so here what I
have is basically the core class in
gradio it's called the interface class
um and the interface class basically
takes in three things which is a
function input and output so function
here is your machine learning models
prediction function so here could be
something that you know takes in some
text and generates images based off of
those texts inputs and outputs actually
refer to one or more built-in gradio
components so gradio ships with 30 odd
components uh so things like text boxes
things like galleries things like you
know charts um things like data
frames and so all of those are kind of
built into gradio so you don't have to
worry about designing them and So based
off of these kind of inputs and outputs
a guey is created for you um and then
you go ahead and you do one more command
uh uh which was uhq and we'll actually
talk about how you no longer even have
to do this but this creates a queueing
system that can handle incoming requests
so now your guey your web app can just
handle many many many requests and then
when you launch it if you add one more
parameter share equals true it actually
creates a public link a public link
where anyone can try out your machine
learning model while it continues to run
locally on your computer so this is
really powerful you don't have to worry
about web hosting you don't have to
worry about AWS you don't have to worry
about anything have to you don't have to
worry about about getting a server
paying for a server this is a free kind
of uh way to share a link with anyone it
could be your colleague your
collaborator your advisor your parents
you know it could be anyone really um
and so yeah so that's kind of the um
maybe if I had to like boil it down this
kind of the the kind of the the most
basic usage of
gradio um we released gradio a few years
ago about 2019 um and in the last few
years this really picked up um
we at this point gradio has about 50,000
um unique monthly active developers at
this point more than 15 million gradio
apps have been built and launched so 15
million people who have you know built
prototypes or or in some cases even very
very full complex web applications this
is the automatic 1111 repo um many of
you may have seen this before it's a um
honestly something that you know is not
something we thought yeah you could
build something like this with gradio
but um there's an entire very very
complex gooey there's a plug-in system
an extension system it's kind of crazy
um that people have built this with
gradio um and
so and then of course there's also
hugging face spaces as well which is the
canonical way to actually deploy gradio
applications again for free if uh if you
want to deploy it on a CPU machine you
can deploy it for free and then you get
all sorts of very very cool uh you know
social features as well people can
discuss your demo people can share
output from your demo and and things
like that um oh yeah so I see here oh
yeah that's thank you Ali Abdullah D
that's correct 500,000 uh monthly active
developers um okay so that kind of uh
leads us to where we're at today so
today is the launch event for gradio 4.0
and uh I'll have the rest of the gradio
team kind of share more about what's you
know what are the concrete features that
we're releasing as part of gradio 4.0
but I just wanted to lay out two broad
principles uh I think that will thread
through all of the conversation for the
rest of the presentation um and that is
one thing that we've realized over the
last couple of years is we can't
anticipate all of the amazing use cases
that the community that you all are
going to make with gradio uh you know
we've seen again people you know try
things that you know inject all sorts of
JavaScript and custom CSS and do things
like that um and so what we've uh
decided uh to do is to try to expose
more and more control to users uh give
more and more control to you all so that
you can customize gradio apps at a at a
in a way that you know current was not
possible before 4.0 so we'll talk about
how we expose the internals of gradio in
the structured manner uh in particular
how you can build custom components so I
mentioned before gradio you know comes
built in with these 30 odd compon
components but let's say you want to do
something that's kind of beyond what
those components allow you'll be able to
do that as part of 4.0 um at the same
time we want gradio to be a really
robust foundation so if you're building
any sort of web app you should have the
confidence to know that these components
are a good starting point so we've
integrated really good you know kind of
best practices when it comes to things
like accessibility within gradio
components we'll talk about that as
well
um okay so with that
uh yeah so the four things we'll talk
about uh today are first of all custom
components second of all media
components we've redesigned them from
scratch uh we'll touch upon
accessibility as well we'll talk about
server side events uh which I think will
be interesting and then finally we'll
talk about custom share servers uh and
there's lots of other stuff that's part
of 4.0 as well unfortunately we probably
won't have time to talk about it we
probably won't have time to cover
everything today but if you have
questions we're happy to answer
questions uh throughout the talk but
also you know towards the end of the
talk we'll we'll dedicate some time for
questions um and then of course
everything will be released uh you'll
have the change log and you'll be able
to see everything that's part of
4.0 so with that I'd like to uh bring up
Pete um who is on the gradio team to the
stage hey Pete hey thanks very much all
right and I'm GNA go ahead and share
your screen so feel free to take it from
here awesome thank you so um as a we've
got mentioned I'm going to talk a little
bit about custom components so you know
it's become clear over the past kind of
probably over the past year or so that
there's an increasing demand for you
know bespoke interfaces that users want
to kind of present to their users so
that they can interact with these models
and it might be um that you someone
wants to build a complex application
that needs some specific controls or it
might just be that they have a very
specific model that needs a very
specific visualization
and so custom components was was born
and and custom components allows you to
build a custom input and custom output
for your machine learning model so it's
pretty much you know Limitless within a
with a certain within a certain set of
bounds obviously so as an
example um this was probably the first
request that we had that we thought
would make sense as a custom component
and this is a an image comparison
slideer you've probably seen these
things um before um it's a really nice
way you can see you can drag and drop um
two images and then upload those to the
gradio server and then you can compare
those images again
and this is not a component that is
available in core but as you can see it
looks exactly like a gradio uh custom
component um it has all the same kind of
UI elements and whatnot but you you know
and this is really just a component that
is a it's a relatively small tweak of an
existing component it was based on our
image component um and the only real
difference is it's got a different UI
and it takes two images instead of one
but you might want to build something
more
complex
entirely and so the uh the always
brilliant simoner who being kind of
helping us test Uh custom components
when we were in pre-release built this
this amazing molecule viewer so a 3D
molecule viewer and we have nothing like
this in gradio we don't have the uh
domain knowledge to do something like
this Justice or to maintain it but Simon
does um and as you can see this is
completely custom you can load in these
uh these models you can toggle a new
screen and all of this will be possible
with custom components um and much more
besides so if you wanted to build you
know just normal UI elements for you
know extra controls to control
parameters if you wanted completely
custom visualizations inputs and outputs
then you can do that
too so we're incredibly excited about
this because I think this uh this
molecule 3D molecule viewer is is kind
of sums up the whole point of custom
components which is we may have some
ideas but when you put this in the hands
of the open source Community when you
put these in the hands of the users
that's when things really start to get
interesting so we just wanted to find a
really simple way that we could allow
people to create develop and even share
their custom components so you can
publish your custom components to pipie
and even if you're not interested in
building custom components using them
should be as as as easy as installing a
new package and just using them um in
your
code
so what do you need to know to start
building custom components
there are relatively few additional
things you need to know um so gradio
core and custom components you know
there's not really a huge distinction
between our components and custom
components they're built in very much
the same way they use Python for the
back end and spelt for the front end
it's the the power couple we never knew
we needed but here we are
and a lot of people may be familiar with
um with python especially if you come
from a data science or machine learning
um background but if you're not it's
obviously an incredibly popular language
with a a wide array of resources and
spelt is a a relative newcomer to the
front end but um it's generally it's
very similar to you know just writing
plain HTML JavaScript and CSS so it
should have a relatively um small
learning curve for most people a lot of
the team um are not frontend engineers
and I don't think anyone other than me
has had prior experience with spelt and
we've had pretty good feedback about how
easy it is to get started so hopefully
it's not too much of a barrier but we
will be sharing more resources to allow
people to get started even if they have
no experience even in
either in terms of gradio itself there's
only three additional Concepts that you
need to you know high level Concepts
that you need to understand in order to
start building custom components so the
first and and probably the most
important and it's something that people
are possibly aware of anyway way is that
gradio components generally come in two
variants there's a static variant and an
interactive variant so I have the the
static variant on on the left here and
it's it's just a simple output it exists
just for displaying data um this is
typically what would kind of act as an
output to your um to your to your model
for your model so it would just be for
displaying images off us displaying text
and the user typically wouldn't be able
to interact with it an interactive
component however
that's where you allow your user to kind
of to to provide you know their own data
so that we can perform a prediction on
it and then the results of that will be
typically sent off somewhere else so
this is the image the interactive image
where you can upload an image you can
drag and drop an image you can capture
from webcam you can paste an image in
and we have a variety of components and
they they not all of them but a lot of
them have an interactive
input everything has a static um variant
but not everything has an interactive
variant but these are the two kind of
modes that a component can be in so
that's something to bear in mind when
you're when you're building it you know
this gives you the opportunity to build
completely bespoke experiences so you
can think really carefully about you
know what do I want the experience for a
user to be when they are kind of
providing their own data versus what do
I want the experience to be for a user
you know when I'm kind of like
displaying the results of a
prediction the second thing and this is
a little a touch more complex but I'll
I'll try and keep it um as
understandable as possible is
processes so we have these kind of
pre-process and post-process methods
that run as part of this uh this kind of
pipeline um when you kind of perform a
prediction with gradio so if you've you
know B showed the code before and if
you've used gradio before you will know
that you know with interface you
typically have a an input component you
have a predict function that's actually
going to do the do the work and then you
have an output component processes run
at either side of your user function so
we have a pre-processor that will run
before the user function runs and we
have a postprocessor that will run after
the user function
runs this really gives you the so the
the data that comes into the pre-process
it's already kind of python data types
um so you've got kind of like real
python um data structures to work with
but it allows you an opportunity to kind
of provide your users with a better
experience so for example the image when
the image is sent from the front end
it's just a reference to a file now you
could just pass that reference to the
file to the user and let them load that
file into memory and turn it into a real
image that they can you know do
something with but what the image
component actually does is it allows the
user to decide what type do they want
that image in so they can have that
image as a file path so they can indeed
treat it as a file but they can also get
it as a nump right they can also get it
as a pillow image and this is where the
pre-processor comes in so we will take
this file data we will load the file and
then we will instantiate a new pillow
image or a new numpy array and that is
what we pass then into the user function
and the same is kind of true essentially
on the other
side you know we're returning you know
what whatever we want the user to be
able to return you might want them to
just return something um like whatever
they've kind of taken in you might want
to return that um so this allows us to
convert again that kind of very specific
data structure that you know it's it's
hard for gradio to know about every
possible kind of class that exists in in
all of python so this is an opportunity
for you to kind of convert that into a
plain python data structure so that we
can serialize it and send it back down
to the front end where it will be
received as you know some kind of you
know Json or something that we can uh
easily transport and then render in the
front end so this is well it is a
slightly more complex concept and it's
typically not something that people have
had to deal with before it is an
important part of um custom components
you don't have to do anything in these
instances necessarily we certainly have
some components that don't pre or
postprocess um in any meaning f Way um
but it does offer you an opportunity to
provide like really really nice apis so
in the instance of the image we have
this type keyword argument and you can
pass you know numpy pill or file path
and that dictates the data structure
that the user receives in their function
and and likewise these these pre and
post-process methods they aren't always
a mirror of one another but that is kind
of frequently the case um so this is an
important concept that will make a lot
more sense when you actually start
building and you have a have a need for
this um but it is it is a core concept
of custom components and the final
concept is examples so if you've ever
used a gradio app or built one you might
know about this g. examples or g. data
set um which is what examples is under
the hood or you may have just kind of
clicked on these examples to populate
the uh the components on on the
screen the way that these examples are
created is that every component has an
example component and as with everything
else when you're building a custom
component you two can provide a custom
example component and the example
component will receive the example that
is being set so in these cases we've got
you know a mix we've got a multi select
obviously takes a a list of options an
image takes an an image you know video
or video um and you can decide how you
would like to render that example and
typically it's a you know a kind of like
a a slightly reduced version of the uh
of the core components but you can do
whatever you want and it's it's worth
mentioning that these examples they will
also receive all of the keyword
arguments that the component takes as
well so if your component renders very
very differently depending on what kind
of options are passed you have access to
those options in examples too and this
allows us to render your component um
alongside you know one of these could be
your custom component and you wouldn't
know it was a custom component it fits
perfectly into the UI and so these
examples are optional we do have a
fallback where we'll just render the
value but if you have a you know
particularly
engaging um or bespoke custom component
you might want
to you might want to provide a custom
example too so what is it like to build
a custom component so I'm going to hand
over to Freddy now and he's going to
he's going to talk us through the
process of actually creating a custom
component hello everyone uh let me uh
close this for now um I'm Freddy nice to
show you guys or nice to meet you all
and I'm excited to show you uh how you
can get started uh building custom
components uh directly with uh gradio
4.0 so the main way that you create Uh
custom components is via command line
interface that we are launching that we
just launched uh that's called a gradio
component or gradio CC so uh if you have
the latest gradio installed um you do
gradio CC help and then you get a list
of all the commands that you can do uh
with custom components um the first step
of creating a custom component is to
create the scaffolding of your of your
project right so you do that with the
create command um
so and before I get started I just want
to maybe I should say like what it is
that I'm going to show you I'm going to
show you guys a custom component to
display uh map data with gradio so we've
gotten some requests in the past about
improving um gradio support for
geospatial data uh I'm going to show you
how you can just unblock yourself now
wait on us and just build your own
custom component to do that so the way
that we're going to that is we're going
to use a python Library called folium
that it's like a pythonic API for
creating Maps um okay so with that said
um the first thing we're going to do is
uh we're going to create our uh our our
component so I'm going to call it
um radi CC
create um my folium and then you'll get
started um so what this is is doing it's
it's creating a directory for you it's
creating some scaffolding backend code
front end code um it's installing any
python dependencies so radio in this
case and it's also installing uh the
JavaScript files um that that come uh
with with the component so that's how
you how you get like how you get started
um so rather than me typing all of these
uh me rather than you uh rather than you
seeing me type I'm going to show you
guys um what the finished code looks
like um and just to show you all the
features so this is what the um this is
what the directory looks like so there
is
a uh a backend folder a demo folder with
the demo to show off in tester component
a front-end folder and then a PR project
uh Tomo file and the read me so in the
toml file um you know here you you pick
the name of your package the version
number um you know you you configure
your project via this file um and then
importantly you list the dependencies
that you need here so in this case I
manually edited this file to add the
folium dependency uh the gradio
dependency was already set by the
CLI um and then you know I'm just going
to kind of go through uh the backend and
front end changes and then show you guys
the demo at the end so in the backend
everything is implemented in this python
file so by default it's the name of the
component uh the name of the component
that you chose so in my case I chose
folium
test um and then you know this is if
you're familiar with python um you know
this is like a normal python class with
the only gradio specific exception being
that we're subclassing the component
class so this is how you declare a
custom component in
gradio um and then we're just going to
go top to bottom here so this is how you
define the events for your component so
you just specify a list with all the
different events that it can take in
this case I'm just going to support and
implement the change event um but you
can pretty much put anything in here as
long as it can be a valid python method
name uh and then whatever you add here
will be a method available on your
component that you can use to trigger an
event um and then the other big thing or
the other new thing if you're familiar
with how gred 3.0 works that's new and
grader 4.0 is this idea of the data
model so the data model is how you
specify the data that um your component
will receive and send back to the server
so it's it's very intricately tied to
the pre-process and post-process concept
that Pete talked about earlier um yeah
basically the server will send you your
data model uh and then you're expected
to return your data model uh from
postprocess um um and then you know this
is I'm just going to create my class I'm
only going to add two keyword arguments
just height and label um and then just
set the height uh of my class and then
the preprocess we're not really doing
anything here because I'm envisioning
this component being used mainly as
output so we don't really have to do
anything from for the
pre-process um and then for the
postprocess uh what we're going to do is
just uh take a folium map so this is
what the user will return from their
python function they're going to return
an instance of the of the map class from
Fon and then what greo is going to do
under the hood is just turn that into an
HTML file that does uh the front end can
serve um so that's what I'm doing here
I'm just creating an HTML file saving it
to that directory and then I'm returning
the file data which is my data model um
you know which just telling telling the
server where to get this file from and
what the original name of it
is uh cool so now let's go to uh the
front end so um the main entry point for
all your front end files will be an
index that's SP and here's the example
that's felt that Pete was talking about
earlier so um over here is just some
standard uh gradio Imports that come
built in with your component and then
the only thing I I modified was to you
know type the value as a file data um
and then all I did here was just that um
if the value is set I just embed an
iframe pointing to the
URL uh of the value and then if it's not
set it we just have like a like an empty
box to let the user know that the value
has not been set yet so I think I went a
little bit fast but at the end of the
day what you need to do is just go to
your python file Define your events and
your data model and then you implement
pre and postprocess and then you just
make whatever front end modifications
you need to display your component so in
this case since we're justplaying HTML
file we could just use an i frame okay
so once you have you know built and
created your component uh your component
uh the next exy thing you can do is kind
of test it out locally before you
publish it so to do that uh CLI comes
with a Dev command so you do radio CC
Dev from within the directory of your
custom
component um and then this will launch
uh the app.py file in the demo
directory uh
uh in a frontend server so you go to
this URL here that says frontend
server
go uh oh here we go sorry uh so here's
my demo uh so I'm going to show you guys
what the demo code looks like so what
we're doing is just that we're picking
uh a city in the world and then when we
click on the radio button uh you'll
you'll get a map of you know a map
centered on that City uh so that's just
kind of what we're doing here just you
know standard radio block syntax and
then we set up our our uh um our select
event on the
radio and then here's the map that we're
returning uh so let's see how that
works
so
yes okay I think I think there's a bug
where the the name isn't matching but
you get the idea that uh this the city
changes with the with the map um but
okay and then another cool thing I want
to show you guys is that this server
reloads all your Python and front end
codes automatically um so you don't have
to restart the server every time you
need to make a change so for example if
I just want to change the label to
map uh you can see that the label
changed automatically um I think there
was a little do there cool um and then
the other thing I want to show you is uh
with the index the same thing happens
with the uh the index uh the spel file
so if we change the icon of the empty
box to be a file instead of a plot uh
you see that has a a file icon now uh
but now it changes to a plot yeah so you
can uh edate really quickly on your
custom component by modifying uh the
backend and front end files uh cool so
I'm pretty happy with what this
component is doing right now save that
bug that'll fix later um but um right so
once you um have implemented both the
front end and back end of your component
um what you can do is build it so you do
gradio CC build and then what this will
do is it'll package all of your frontend
assets and uh your python code and build
a wheel file or a python package that
anyone can install so we'll see we'll
get give it a a little bit time to do
that so here this is what what it
created created this wheel file as well
as the source
distribution um so you could install
this right now in huging face spaces or
you could send this file to anyone and
they can install it locally and they'll
be able to use your component in any
gradio demo um but it would be cooler if
they didn't need this file at all they
could just download it if they could
download this file themselves from the
internet so Gro makes it really easy for
you uh with the publish
command uh so the publish command walks
you through the process of sharing your
component so there's two parts you can
upload to pipie and upload to hugging
face faces so we're going to do both as
we're going to upload to piie uh you
need is a Pipi account and here it tells
you where to go to uh to create one so
I'm going to just give it my
credentials and then here you go it's
uploading to
piie um that's the link and then it also
asks you to upload a demo to Huggy pay
spaces if you'd like and by default
it'll upload the demo that you created
locally so yeah by default it's the the
demo
directory um and then it also ask you if
you like to share your source code so
that people can look at the
implementation and you know Fork it from
hugging face and make modifications so
we're going to uh we're going to do that
as well and
then it's going to upload to uh hugging
face spaces so then if I go here uh I
see the
demo uh so it's already running on
hugging
face um and then here we see the source
code and then if I go back
here uh it creates a a ppie project for
you so now anyone can install this in
their machine on collab they can put
this in their requir cxt file in hugging
phas um and they'll be able to use this
component um in their in their demo um
as long as they have radio
4.0 so stop sharing now um so that's uh
all I had to show you guys uh thank you
guys uh so much and yeah really excited
to see the custom components that you
build thanks Freddy uh we have a uh
We've also put together a written guide
for how to create custom components uh
so that's published on the gradio
website uh and then we'll be sharing
that afterwards as well so we're going
to go ahead and change gears now so
we've talked about custom components and
we talked about custom components at
length just for the sake of time the
other items that we're going to talk
about are going to be much faster but
I'm going to hand it over to Hannah
who'll be talking about the media
components thank you um hi everyone nice
to meet you all um I'm Hannah one of the
frontend developers on the team um and
yeah I wanted to talk to you today about
the media components that we've uh we're
releasing which we refresh a little bit
um so firstly we have the
uh oh go to the next
slide uh so we have the video component
so um before it was a nice looking video
component um but we've now added some
functionality to trim the videos um so
yeah you can see from the um yeah from
the screenshots you can just trim a
selection of the video so people can
upload a certain amount to um run
through the prediction certain part of
the video to run through theed the
prediction function um yeah you can trim
it and then you can also revert it to
the original
state um another part of this as well is
that we've added Source selection so
before we were only able to select
whether it was um an upload or webcam
input but now people can switch between
the two which is
great um and yeah here's a little demo
of how that looks if that's
running um I'm not sure if it'll play
that through streamyard but oh maybe not
well come to the next
one um so this is the uh image component
um that's also had a bit of a refresh
which is great so this too has had um a
changes to the source selection um so
you can now upload and select capturing
via webcam and also copy and paste into
the
component and lastly the audio component
um so before again we had um this audio
sort of view and you could also trim it
obviously as some people know um but now
we've actually added sort of a waveform
view uh corresponding to the audio so
when people record they can see the uh
live waveform and also when they output
they can see the waveform of that audio
um on top of this as well as a video you
can also trim it you can edit it um and
of course you can change the playback
speed of the audio um and again Source
selection as well so you can change um
um whether you upload the file or also
um capture via microphone um so that's
awesome another thing as well is um Min
and max length parameters have been
added to both audio and video so now you
can specify whether um how how short or
long the audio or video can be uh sent
through the pro
function um and this is a an example of
the K xtts uh space which is currently
trending um this is what it looked like
before um still works it's very cool um
and now this is uh it with the new audio
component um and yeah I said this is
trending so you can give this a go and
um yeah have a play around with this
space which is really cool um so yeah so
we fixed up a few bug fixes with these
components um improve the accessibility
and the ux um as I mentioned as well
trimming uh min max length um copying
image from clipboard into G image and
multiple sources so yeah very excited
about that
um and just so to touch on accessibility
as well so this is the c key space um
and it's also navigable by the naval by
the keyboard so you can trim you can use
the um handles on either side you don't
have to use a mouse or anything so um
all very accessible which is great um so
yeah so to expand on accessibility um
with the growth of our monthly active
users we've been very mindful of making
this much more of a priority to make
sure our spaces are accessible to every
um as anyone knows who's who's worked on
accessibility it's always a a never
ending feat trying to improve it but we
I feel like we've made loads of progress
in the past few months on it which I'm
really really proud about um and yeah so
we've had an audit of all of our
components made sure their keyboard
accessible um we've made sure that we've
improve the HTML semantics so that uh
the apps are meaningful for all screen
readers um icons as well is everything
is labeled as uh necessary um we've been
very mindful of the colors that we've
been using um making sure that it's very
readable with people with certain needs
um on screens and we're going to be
carrying out a lot more accessibility
AUD uh audits going ahead um so yeah
very excited about that really proud of
what we're doing um P more updates
coming in the future because as I said
it's there's always room for improvement
but um yeah very very happy with where
we are
now so yeah that's all for me thank you
rmon thank you so much Hannah that's
awesome um okay so we are going to
change gears yet again uh and we're
going to talk about one more uh change
in uh gradio 4.0 uh this is a pretty big
change and here we have ali uh talking
about it all right hey guys uh yeah
we're going to shift gears a little bit
I'm going to talk a little bit about how
we change some of the protocols that uh
we use for communication between the
gradio front end and the back end um and
so previously we um we used two types of
requests to communicate between the
server and the client and the server we
used HTTP post requests for quick uh
like updates we'd send the data payload
we got a response back um but that those
had some limitations so the problem with
um uh HTP post requests there basically
two problems that uh we ran into was
that first one was that uh any type of
HTTP request like that times out in 60
seconds so if you had any complex app or
you had like a bunch of requests piling
up and it took you know two minutes to
get a response from your app which is
not uncommon in a heavy machine learning
app um the the request would just time
out the other problem was that you
couldn't send um any messages along with
the output during the processing of the
function so a lot of features within
gradio so for example sending updates on
how long the queue is going to take or
if your function is an iterator getting
the yielded outputs um things like that
require sending data along with while
the function is running and a a post
request only sends one piece of data to
the server and the server sends one
piece of data back and so uh we needed
to in gradio 3.x we added support for
websockets because websockets support by
directional flow so we could be sending
messages back and forth from the client
to the server and that's how we were
able to support features like uh updates
in your queue like uh iterative outputs
like uh popup info warning models that
can come up while the function is
running um but websockets came with uh a
bit of baggage of their own um they are
a little unwieldy they're not easy to
set up behind a server they're not easy
to do load balancing with and so we
moved over to a new protocol and we've
unified what previously we had HTT post
requests used sometimes and websockets
use sometimes now we've unified
everything to use serers side events um
so serers side events are simil similar
to web stockus in that there is uh
multiple messages being sent but the the
difference is that there's only one
message sent from the client to the
server and then the server is sending
messages throughout uh can send multiple
messages back to the client so if you
see the websocket example there request
going back and forth whereas the service
Side Event were getting updates from the
server uh there's a unidirectional after
the first response is sent um so why do
we care about that why should you care
um the reason is the service side events
are just much better uh supported across
pretty much everything because they are
simply just a text HTTP protocol so this
means better device support we get you
know more Mobile support better handling
if the connection drops off better
scaling if you are serving your gradio
app behind an Apachi server on adws
using load
balance it also makes it much easier to
integrate with other Technologies
because websockets are kind of unwieldy
whereas you can use just a straightup
curl command to integrate into uh your
gradio app so in this example here I
have I just curl my Local Host uh where
the queue is running and I'm getting
responses back so you're basically
running gradio literally in your
terminal um which is which will allow
you to integrate or use gradio as a
backend much more easily um obviously we
do have a whole gradio client separate
library that makes it e uh that provides
more helpers to use gradio as an API but
just using a simpler better supported
technology I think will allow will
encourage people to use gradio as a
backend um uh much more
comfortably um so along with this uh
while we were unifying how we handle our
requests uh not only did we unify what
protocol we're using but we also unified
uh the queuing mechanism so previously
we uh we had the option where you could
have your quests be queued up or they
could not be queued up and these were
two separate ways and there were some
features that were supported with the
queuing system and some that were not we
kind of unified everything now
everything uses one queue and you have
much more better control of this Quee of
requests that are being handled um so in
greo 3. previously we had uh if you
enabled a queue you had one Q you had a
specific set of workers and as their
requests came in they would get piled
into the queue and workers would take
them off one by one and you had some
control over the flow of this queue you
could set the number of workers so if
you knew that you know your uh app
couldn't handle you know serving 20 to
request because some of your uh event
listeners have heavy machine learning
processing you could control how many
workers are being sent uh but you didn't
have very fine uh fine grain control so
it could happen that if you had like one
heavy machine learning request that's
taking 20 seconds to parse and then
another user submits a very quick uh
request of a different event listener
that just needs to maybe update the UI
or do something simple it would get
stuck behind the other Q request and
then that one would take 20 seconds
because it's waiting in que and so we
wanted to make it so that you have much
finer grain uh control over your queue
and so you moved away from this s single
shared Q system where it it's still one
q but now you can specify how many
workers are dedicated for each task so
let's say for example your web app has
one um machine learning model inference
which requires GPU and then has another
function that um maybe saves some files
on dis that takes you know maybe a
couple seconds and then it has another
function that just updates the UI
you may want it so that your machine
learning model only has MA a maximum of
two threads working uh at most at once
because any more than that then you're
constrained by GPU and you'd run into
errors you might want the file system
one to maybe have more workers maybe at
maximum 10 work can be working in
parallel and then your last one the one
that's just a UI update you could have
like 20 work workers at most working in
parallel now you can set this per event
listener this way events of different
types aren't blocking each other
necessarily so if there's one very heavy
type of event it's not blocking the
queue for the other events you have fine
grain control of how many workers are
set per event um and we think that this
will allow like much finer grained um
control of how your flow works and how
your queue is set up so we've unified
not only the protocol but also that the
fact that the all the requests are being
surfed through this queue and you have
much more uh finer control over that um
yeah that's pretty much everything for
me uh thanks for listening
guys all right thanks so much ali
um
and let's uh change gears yet again and
now we'll talk about the the final uh
new uh kind of feature in gradio 4.0 of
course there's a bunch of other things
that we won't have time to cover but the
last thing that we wanted to cover in
this presentation which is custom share
servers okay so if anyone has created a
gradio app before and I mentioned this
at the beginning of the talk as well you
know that you can easily create a public
link for your gradio demo right all you
do is you do. launch share equals true
and you get a public link that looks
something like this some uh different
hexadecimal kind of digits and then
gradio
dolive now this is fine uh but how does
this actually work so what's actually
happening under the hood when these
these public links are created is that
gradio continues running on your local
computer um and so your your gradio
application runs locally on a server
that's been created um and then gradio
uses something known as fast reverse
proxy and what that does is it exposes
your local Port so your local Port gets
Exposed on a public machine on a public
server and that public server has a
public IP address which kind of forwards
requests uh which forwards requests to
your develop to your machine and then
your machine takes those prediction
sends it back to the gradio share server
and then which then sends that back to
the users on the internet and so from
the perspective of a user they're just
using a web page but what's actually
happening is that the gradio share
server is kind of message passing you
know back and forth in order to make
this work now the big new thing in
gradio 4.0 is that this share server
that's in the middle here it doesn't
have to be gradio share server anymore
it can be any share server meaning that
let's say you have a startup uh or you
have a company that you work for let's
call it my GPT rapper.com now what you
can do is you can set up a share server
on your own domain and so and once that
happens once once you set up a share
server on your own domain you can
actually point gradio to it and gradio
will create a link that's a that's kind
of a share link on that on that domain
and so practically speaking what we've
done is we've open- sourced the actual
last piece of gradio that wasn't already
open sourced which is this share server
uh that's based on FR FRP so we've open
sourced this you can see exactly the
code that we have for our share server
and that exactly so Dale mentioned that
you know that 72 hours limit is irksome
when you set it up on your own devices
on your own machines on your own servers
you don't have to have any sort of
timeout or you can increase the timeout
you have full control over the code and
we've actually you know laid out
instructions describing how to change
the timeout or how to do whatever you
want in order to uh uh you know set up
this share server so that you or your
colleagues can do it and then in terms
of being able to use it within your
gradio application we've added another
parameter uh to launch and that's called
share server address and what that uh
what that parameter takes in is the
domain and the port uh that uh the FR
FRP port and so again all of these
instructions are available but basically
once you do this you get a very nice
kind of you know share link that runs on
your kind of own devices for as long as
you want now of course that is all that
is one way to do it the other day the
other way which is already available and
it's going to be continue continue to be
available is for you to be able to share
your uh gradio demos on H face spaces
and of course we do recommend this
because then you get kind of a lot of
nice features like discussions and so on
and who knows you might be able to get
custom domains as well uh just stay
tuned if you're interested uh in
that sweet um with that we're going to
start actually closing things up so
there's a lot of other stuff that we
didn't get a chance to talk about uh
proper support for JavaScript functions
uh much uh better file security so if
you're uh worried about you know users
being able to access files on your
computer we've you know we've revamped
this um you can you can have a lot more
control over
uh the uh meta tags in your gradio
application uh the any sort of
JavaScript you want to inject such as
Google analytics things like that you
can now do that in gradio 4.0 you can
even control exactly which events get
processed when and concurrently uh using
a new parameter we added called trigger
mode these are things that if people
have questions we're happy to talk about
but just for the sake of time I think
we'll we'll we uh we'll uh pause there
um yes thank you so much much everyone
for joining us today and we'll take a
little bit of time maybe 10 minutes or
so to to answer any questions during
this live stream and then of course
we're happy to answer questions after
the live stream on Twitter and on on
Discord those are the two places where
the team hangs out so feel free to find
us afterwards and we're happy to help
you upgrade to the latest version of
gradio are there any questions uh that
that you all have uh for the gradio team
while you have us
here really want custom domains awesome
perfect yeah so it's supported in gradio
and it'll be supported uh in uh spaces
probably soon so stay tuned for
that uh so we have a question about
release notes um release notes I think
should be available maybe ali uh can uh
maybe Ali
can chime in on that
Ali abdah if you want to respond in the
chat that'd be great as well uh so a
good question from mik um do we have
backwards compatibility as we have many
demos uh that's a great question so
gradio 4.0 being a major version uh
there are some breaking changes um there
aren't too many and depending on the
complexity of your gradio app it might
be possible that you can just upgrade
and your code works as is the UI will
look a bit different and that's
intentional of course but if your app
uses certain things you might have to
actually change the code a little bit
there might be some breaking changes uh
part of the release notes covers it's
kind of like a migration guide so a list
of all of the breaking changes and what
you need to do in order to uh start
using gradio
4.0
cool uh there was couple other questions
uh is this presentation online anywhere
uh I believe it will be it will be um I
think it'll be available on YouTube uh
after this live stream is is
finished uh question from Jackie Le how
can I dis how can I disable waveform
displaying audio component uh currently
not possible uh We've designed it in a
way that hopefully won't be too
extrusive but if that is important to
you please open an issue and we can
consider it uh but also now you have the
power to do custom components so you can
create your own custom audio component
that you know it's kind of you know
doesn't have this s way form if you so
want um does gradio light work with
gradio V4 uh yeah so good question um so
gradio light is pinned to a specific
version of gradio so every release of
gradio light is spined to a specific
version of gradio so the current version
of gradio light that is released is spin
to gradio 3.x so that's actually a good
question a caveat that you should know
of but we'll soon upgrade it we'll see
we'll release a new version of gradio
light that is fully compatible with
gradio
4.0
um question about projects related to
gradio uh this is a good question maybe
if anyone from the community wants to
suggest
projects um for this LinkedIn uh person
feel free to suggest projects
there uh so Dale so I can't use it right
now so you should be able to pip install
gradio 4.0 uh you should be able to try
it if it doesn't work uh let us know or
feel free to create an issue but it
should
work sweet are there any other
questions all right well once again uh
on behalf of the whole team thank you so
much for joining us today um and feel
free to find us on social media if you
have any questions and we're happy to
help so good luck
building
for